وبعمليه الاطلاق هذه تكون كوريا الشماليه
قد اختتمت هذا العام سلسله غير مسبوقه من
التجارب الصاروخيه وسط تصاعد توتر في شبه
الجزيره الكوريه اذا شاهد عام 2022 اطلاقا
اليونغ يونغ 73 صاروخا لاسيا وهو اكثر من
ضعف سنها الثانويه السابق ومن بين هذه
التجارب كانت هناك ثمان منها لصواريخ
عابره للقارات اعتبر تصعيدا للاعمال
العدائيه تجاه جيرانها وكان الشهر الاول
من عام 2012 قد شهد وحده سبع تجارب
صاروخيه وهو اعلى رقم تجريه في شهر واحد
منذ تنصيب
في سده الحكم نهايه عام 2011 وفي مارس
اذان الماضي اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الكوريه
الجنوبيه اثنتين من التجارب الصاروخيه
لجارتها شماليه شملت صواريخ لسيه جديده
عابره للقارات تطورها بيونغيانغ سرا مدعيه
انها تجارب اطلاق قمر صناعي للاستطلاع